the FBI is asking Apple to weaken the
security of our products hackers and
cyber criminals could use this to wreak
havoc on our privacy and personal safety
you used to let me in your cell phone
now you say you're not so sure but the
government just found a telephone it
can't ignore I know where NAT i phone
bling that can only mean one thing I
know when that iPhone bling I can only
mean one thing
get your ass in here and make me soft
well do we will be jailed I know it's
scary but they're terrorists so get up
on your chair we are making OS less
secure than Nashville Marriott the
government and cell phones dangerous
combination yes like diet coke and
mentos like credit cards and Kanye
I know when that I phone bling that can
only mean one thing
get your ass in here and make my
software our signing key is locked up
like it's Fort Knox don't worry about
China they got for us sir are you
familiar with Pandora's box you know I
don't watch porn we need a back door
surprise like the time to see fell off
by by we need a back door surprise oh
yeah we do oh yeah we do all that we do